but first Lucas Tomlinson at the
Pentagon on Shogun's parting shots
against the Washington political culture
good evening Lucas Bret president Trump
used an event in Ohio today to defend
the firing of his Veterans Affairs
Secretary dr. David Shulkin I wasn't
happy with the speed with which our
veterans were taken care of we made
changes because we want them taking care
of we want them to have choice so that
they can run to a private doctor shokan
wasn't too happy about getting axed and
took out his frustrations in a
blistering op-ed this morning saying
quote Washington has turned so toxic
chaotic disrespectful and subversive
that it became impossible for me to
accomplish the important work that our
veterans need the former secretary blink
Riddick's for making false accusations
against him they saw me as an obstacle
to privatization calls for the Obama
holdovers removal boiled over following
an ethics scandal but Shulkin was quick
to point out his successes expanding
access to health care reducing wait
times and working closer with the
private sector Shogun says the
percentage of veterans who regain trust
in the VA has risen from 46 percent four
years ago to 70 percent today still he
struggled to win over Congress and even
vets you led me to believe that you and
I were on the same page our inability to
reach an agreement is in significant
part related to your ability to speak
out of both sides of your mouth
double-talk
Sara Farrar doz husband has had more
than a hundred surgeries since being
wounded in Afghanistan she says she's
ready for change we need a secretary in
there who is empowering and enacted the
president's plan it's a system that
needs massive and total overhaul it's a
stain on our nation and we we owe these
heroes so much more president Trump's
nominee to replace Shulkin Rear Admiral
Ronnie Jackson some people have you know
just great genes the White House
position best known as the doctor who
delivered the briefing on president
Trump's physical is already coming under
fire for his credentials some question
whether the Navy doctor can successfully
lead the federal government's
get largest apartment the oldest war
veterans organizations saying quote dr.
Jackson's bio does not reflect any
experience working with the VA or with
veterans or managing any organization of
this size on Monday acting VA secretary
Robert Wilkie takes over on an interim
basis it could be months before Jackson
is confirmed
Brett Lucas thank you